[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Liana galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 321
aka the penultimate episode of Riverdale
third season I can see the light at the
end of The Gargoyle King film tunnel you
guys as always we're gonna be doing our
live Q&A at the end of this and I'll be
gifting you with my three clues and as a
special bonus I'll be debuting a game I
created which had Michael Murray called
never have I ever
with Edgar ever and ever honestly I
think the name of that game is one of
the few things for you me joy at this
point but first let's check out your
hisses kisses comments and theories that
you've been leaving for me and our
Sweetwater after show for episode 3 2255
calm night now kicking this off
CJ Brown commented hisses to hell for
playing Betty this is to Evelyn for
denying Cheryl prom queen
kisses to Shoney's adorable slow dance
pisses to the farm in general I know I
know we're all tired of the farm but
we're also probably all agreeing with
Karina mm who's shared even though I
really hate Edgar not gonna lie I really
enjoyed that shirtless scene he had yep
even though Edgar is filled with all
kinds of Eagle even evil at least he
looks nice shirtless next up Sophie as
Dale gave us her take on a new meme
saying no one Riverdale riders let's
bring back the black hood storyline yeah
I don't think anyone asked for this but
Julia Willam is sweetly trying to make
the best of a bad situation and
suggesting I love the idea of calling
the black hood the black hook from now
on who's with me
sure Julia let's just ride this wave of
crazy until it drowns us meanwhile
Amisha Elega commented major hisses to
hiram please just go away we don't like
you and this is where we all do the
Sherrill version of
fact and Caroline Divini also shared her
hilarious take writing Betty my serial
killer father escaped from prison and is
trying to kill me
alongside The Gargoyle King meanwhile my
entire family is deep into a cult and
are dragging my friends with them Archie
I just want a box how Archie I'd really
like to know what you were taking to
have those bruises heal so quickly
because I'm constantly bumping into
things because I'm graceful as hell and
I'm left with dark marks for a week so
please share your secrets moving on
Malan Andre wrote kisses to the
wonderful Lily Reinhardt her acting this
episode was beyond anything I've ever
seen
I'm gonna be honest with you guys Lily
Rinehart's acting is the only thing
that's getting me and my editor Hank
through these episodes anymore we love
her we think she's super talented and
she can do no wrong and lastly Betty
Jones added and kisses to LeAnn for
chick beam for chick pea in The Gargoyle
King because I agree why thank you Betty
Jones in fact a lot of you agreed with
my theory about chip being The Gargoyle
King so I guess we're just going to have
to wait and see if my really good theory
is actually what happens live for now
let's take a look at the promo for
episode 321 big changes coming to
Riverdale
if I win you walk away from Riverdale
dumb your peers we are all in danger now
you just sound cuckoo BAM you're not
gonna win this says who
kill it
the king I can tell you who he is
that's impossible
mm-hmm does that get you pumped up do
you need a little bit more I sure do
well then how about I share my three
clues for chapter 56 this secret of
harvest house number one pay close
attention to the title of this episode
it has a massive spoiler hidden in plain
sight number two if you thought one
character was ready to break free well
then you're going to be wildly
disappointed and number three I think
it's time we fire the colonel family
because they are the worst most corrupt
and inaccurate coroner's ever and you
may think you know what I'm referring to
on that last clue but trust me you don't
switch in Gears I know you all are
feeling a little mm-hmm shall we say
exasperated as we're wrapping up this
third season of Riverdale and it's very
obvious that I am too sorry not sorry
so I thought I'd play a little game with
star Chad Michael Murray to lighten the
mood so please sit back relax and enjoy
one of my favorite ideas that I've ever
created for you guys
I'm Chad Michael Murray and we're about
to play never have I ever with Edgar
ever never never have I ever
snapped a selfie with the Zoe dang Goran
Mazal no I've never heard it's not a
selfie I don't think it snaps up oh yeah
she was in that selfie but I didn't snap
it but I was in a large selfie with
machen and a whole bunch of us farmy
types never have I ever had Riverdale
fans slide into my DMS
I don't know I between you and I if you
notice I'm rarely ever on social media
forgive me but if you're there
hi it's nice to see but I never go on
there when I do it's to say hello and
post and then move on I never had
I ever worked out with KJ and Charles
you know what I got to be honest I'm a
little bummed out that I haven't I
didn't find out about this until the end
and I do think KJ actually invited me
the first day I came in but I was so
overwhelmed trying to remember
everybody's names and meet everybody
because high-caste old cast there's Chad
Chad whole cast but I know I heard that
they all train and he trains with Mark
and Charl I would like so I might just
have to venture up there again and make
sure that that happens
have I ever shared a scene with both
matching and skeet how wouldn't you like
to know no I haven't I ever been
recognized on the street as Edgar never
not yet but I've been asked if I'm a
cult leader before so that's close
enough
have I ever wanted to move to the farm
never thought about it first time has
ever crossed my brain pan
so um I've wanted to move to a farm I
like forums my course and stuff like
chickens but no never no farms for me
have I ever felt overwhelmed by the
power of the Riverdale fandom no no no I
embrace you guys I love you guys I think
you guys are absolutely incredible and I
know that the cast that has been there
since day one I know that they
appreciate every single one of them I
hear about it all the time because you
guys are awesome you're the reason
they're there have I ever been weirded
out that I'm now playing a parent on the
CW so whoever asked this question you
trying to date me here when you trying
to make me won't make me feel a little
old getting not no not yes in the middle
it's interesting I started when I was 19
on Gilmore Girls and 20 on Dawson's and
I turned 21 when I started shooting One
Tree Hill so for me it's it's incredibly
surreal to be a 37 year old man who has
kids now playing a father on Riverdale
it's incredibly cyclical and very cool
it's blows my mind now if there was a
vanilla milkshake in this you would also
know that that's probably my favorite
dessert tree I love a good vanilla
milkshake
and that concludes our never have I ever
with Edgar
ever never featuring okay did you enjoy
that I did start telling me because now
it's time for our live Q&A all right
guys
you are already flooding all of my
mentions right now and apparently you
like my juggy beanie my thank you I like
it too it's real messy under here but
this is hiding it maybe that's why he
wears it all the time
okay kicking us off Ryan hence Allah
says Shoni better have some good scenes
tonight because we were robbed last week
of Cheryl accepting prom queen after
Betty couldn't yeah apparently someone
said that there was a deleted scene
where Cheryl goes up there and takes the
crown I didn't know if that was just a
rumor if that actually happens but I
still AM crushed that we did not get to
see two prom queens to see Shoni up
there that would have been amazing break
the traditions guys
Jennifer Rose 95 I'm hoping Betty has
another reason to be at the farm other
than it may or may not be safe there
also really hope she can break some
people away from the farms clutches oh
goodness guys things inside the farm are
even more insane than you would ever
imagine I'm still processing this week's
episode and you're going to freak out
and I don't know if that's in a good way
or a bad way that's all I'll say for now
until you ask me more elegant my vlogs
bye Maddie hey girl says can we please
get the scripts and gargles crap over
with and go back to normal teen murder
mystery show like it was in season one
preach Maddie
yes I want that too and you know what
you and I always on the same wavelength
because if you tuned in to the
Sweetwater after-show tomorrow you're
gonna be getting an exclusive montage
featuring all of your favorite Riverdale
stars talking about the game of Griffins
and gargoyles and what they really think
about it and it's amazing I've been
holding on to this for the entire season
and now I will share it with you because
it's hilarious moving on we have wow so
many I'm gonna go back up to the
beginning
Sidney O'Connell I just want the
gargoyle twig man story to be over
Archie's boxing has
more interesting Cheryl and Tony's safe
out for our she's boxing to become more
interesting yeah good luck Cheryl in
Tony to be safe and Veronica to kick
Hyrum out of town is that too much to
ask
Oh Sidney I do not think that's too much
to ask because I think that's what we
all want at this point and I understand
that they have to have some natural
roadblocks in a season of television to
make things interesting and interesting
for us so that once we get our happy
endings it'll mean more but yes I do not
know how many more times I can watch
Archie box while it's set to a song but
don't worry you're gonna get at least
one more time um
CJ Brown says I just really want to know
why Tony was running away and why Cheryl
was fighting and why literally no one
noticed the Ethel was fat come assuming
that's the end of her or their quote or
why Ethel was gone yeah you guys I
noticed Ethel was gone couldn't remember
her name because she's been gone for so
long I don't know why the cast hasn't
those characters in Riverdale haven't
noticed it but maybe because they've
been dealing with a bunch of crazy
things and the fact that they had the
deadliest prom ever which by the way is
anybody thinking about that at this
point murderers are just like oh look
someone is murdered crazy okay
I want to know what's up with bug head
I'd like to know what's up with bug head
- they're still together same stuff yeah
and you guys want that show neeti osho
Nietzsche we do have some sweet
interactions between Shoni
but given their their headspace you're
not gonna be happy with the interactions
we get I hope that makes sense but I
hope it doesn't okay we have Gracie Mae
McMullen says what if Edgar is actually
playing the black hood to get Betty to
join the farm someone was saying that
they thought that Edgar was the black
hood and they were thinking that that
was a person chasing Betty around prom
but now that we've seen Edgar shirtless
I'm gonna say no that is not the case
because if you look at who was chasing
Betty around the hallways he's a little
Pudge
and we see I think house just a little
Pudge and so clearly it's not edgar
because he is fine Samantha our fellow
says Edgar kept the girl twin to grow
her up and get her pregnant to grow the
farm like in the movie silence oh well I
wouldn't put it past them he's been
calling his wife his daughter and by the
way if you guys looked back at never
have ever with Edgar ever never that I
filmed that with him before I knew that
he was not actually a father on the show
still weird though still weird yeah
they're ready to steal my beanie steal
my beanie it is from Hot Topic
shout-out to hot topics because they've
been pretty much dressing me ever since
Sweetwater start started
thanks guys they want to know if Betty
is getting kidnapped or kidnapped flush
attacked in the promo Betty is getting
attacked every which way this week
physically emotionally mentally and just
when you saw that Lilly Reinhardt
couldn't get any better she does because
the things that she's doing with the
storyline that they're giving her she
needs an Emmy and I'm not just making
that up because she is turning this into
actually great scenes yes Lilly okay
pumpkin face says I'm scared for Toni
after that photo Roberto aguirre-sacasa
posted I mean what even is this please
tell me Toni's okay please tell me that
Cheryl doesn't get kidnapped please
Shoni save each other sony has a very
emotional moment in tonight's episode
and we see one member of the couple do
something sweet for the other person I'm
trying not to give anything away Joanie
is put in a very heightened situation
and they're doing the best they can go
doing the best they can you guys just
like we all are someone commented I
didn't include it in our hisses and
kisses from last week's episode but
someone commented it's clearly Anna so
over Riverdale I'm just gonna clear this
up just a little bit I'm just so tired
back that's really how I am right now
because in addition
to making two episodes of Sweetwater
secrets for you every week I'm also
running point on our Game of Thrones
coverage and Shadowhunters just ended
and the Big Bang Theory and all these
other little finales and arrow and all
this other great stuff that I love doing
for you guys but so when I get these
episodes of Riverdale but make no sense
in my brain yeah I'm gonna start talking
about it because I'm tired of being like
well we'll get them next time no the
season is driving me crazy
when I look at it as a whole it's not my
favorite season I feel like we've really
really really deviated from season 1
Riverdale and of course a show is going
to continue to evolve and grow and and
move us to new places I'm just not
liking this thick mud of gargoyle
that we're in right now still love the
show still appreciate what the writers
do love Roberto aguirre-sacasa love the
cast to pieces and they're doing the
best with what they are giving right now
ok Julia I asked myself if Hal was
really the black hood in the last
episode because he is evil but I would
have never thought that he would try to
kill bel Betty yes I it's like he was I
don't know if you guys watch Game of
Thrones but it's like he was the
mountain he's like now a zombie weirdo
who's only doing what maybe the gargoyle
king is telling him to do I have no idea
the only thing that I will say about the
black hood /black hook is if you don't
like nails on a chalkboard because it
freaks me out and really hurts my brain
you're not gonna like this episode cuz
it really hurts
Scott will hook shiri 101 well our
hearts break for VAR Cheech nyam Roberto
aguirre-sacasa said one of the most
heartbreaking scenes is filmed tonight
and it's with var Chi what can you tell
I am NOT going to say if it's
heartbreaking I'm just gonna say it's
confusing it makes no sense to me I have
no idea what's going on but you know
what I think that yeah thanks for vert
things my director is telling me to fix
my hair back to barchi I will say that I
don't know I don't know anymore you
think that things are going one way they
go another way and
I don't know let's see um
Wesley Hart is there a death tonight I
mean I know that's weird because it's
Riverdale but I'd like a warning I'm not
gonna tell you they want the VAR Chi
Reggie seeing T you guys I just I can't
tell it's just so you'll see it and then
come to the octave show and tell me all
your thoughts about it because I think
we're gonna be on the same wavelength oh
by the way I will be with all of the
cast of Riverdale most of them on Monday
at Charles mountains premiere because
you know I was just at KJ oppas premiere
for the last summer now I'm gonna be at
Charles mountains premiere for the Sun
is also a star and so many of the
Riverdale stars are going to be there so
start commenting once you're done with
this watching me here start commenting
with your questions for the cast about
the Riverdale finale I'll also be
chatting with Roberto aguirre-sacasa to
try and get you guys some answers and
figure out what the heck is going on
we're gonna take just a couple more
episodes rachel bone could Betty be
pregnant because in the bathroom scene
there was a poster saying something like
no teen pregnancy I mean you as always
are asking me if Betty's pregnant and my
answer will always be the same I hope
not
I do not like highschool pregnancy story
lines I I don't like it I think it's
very 90s I think it's not needed and
like to be honest in order to get
pregnant you kind of have to be in the
same scene as your boyfriend so I don't
think so
Julia cursed kamar put in all caps edgar
equals puppeteering vh hiram equals I'm
on it Alice equals clueless how equals
alive that gibberish makes sense and yes
everything you just said yes okay Ruby
Beryl do we find out who the gargoyle
king is in this episode maybe the answer
is maybe the answer is maybe
it doesn't make that Kaitlyn coming
so obviously Betty is undercover at the
farm she is way too smart and headstrong
to be dragged into that whole mess
Betty is amazing and brilliant and yes
we know she's looking to infiltrate the
farm and get some answers that doesn't
mean that she is able to resist
Edgar's manipulation because it goes way
deeper than we ever thought I was
watching this episode and I was just
like are you kidding me and once again
pay attention to the headlines to the
title of this episode because it makes
so much more sense after you watch it
it's crazy okay Caitlin Jones is Cheryl
a big part of the end of the season
we've seen a lot of pictures with her
and with other cast members so it could
be something to do with her being
carried away cheryl is in tonight's
episode and I know she's in the finale
and if you watch Natalie and patches
YouTube stories she did an episode that
I was catching the other day when I was
curling my hair because she's fun to
watch that she had said that she was
holding a baby and we haven't seen that
yet so I'm assuming she holds one of her
little nephews in the finale so
hopefully things are good I don't know I
don't know you as exasperated as I am is
it just me tell me in the comments
because if it's just me I'll so I'll
stop doing this but if you guys are as
confused as I am then yeah star girl am
I the only one who was completely
freaked out by the farm swarming Betty
the other episode and how she didn't
discuss this with anyone but the next
day she just up and visited the farm
normally Betty needs answers and you
know what a hoard of people dressed in
white trying to say that she should join
them that's not gonna deter her from
trying to save her mom and her sister
and her niece and her friends and her
best friend and her cousin from getting
out of the farm she is she's there was a
metal lien Brannon I like your chick
theory but I think Penelope is the
gargoyle King my mom disagrees with me
as she thinks it's too obvious from the
previous two masked antagonists are
members
from the blossom family and then I just
got another note that a lot of you guys
would like to see a female gargoyle king
that would be great I don't think that
we're gonna get that though
um not necessarily that we'd be great of
having it be Penelope but yeah if you
have to see like that's why I liked
Gladys I liked seeing in like how I
liked penny Peabody I liked seeing these
female antagonists maybe that's because
I can identify with them a little bit
more and I think they're fun I think
they add a little bit of a cool
different layer to the show versus just
Hyrum who's just like taking over the
town iron was just playing Monopoly at
this point and we're all losing cumin
Mustapha what do you think of the
Riverdale caste outfits at the Met Gala
I loved them let's talk about this oh my
gosh okay well if you guys follow me on
Twitter which you should not really I
don't care if you can do whatever you
want but if you want to will list my
Twitter at some point um I tweeted that
I couldn't breathe when I saw Lilly and
Cole's outfits because they looked so
great you guys they looked like they
were straight out of The Hunger Games
and like dressed at the Capitol and I
loved the fact like everyone at et was
talking about the fact that Cole went
for it and he fully embraced the look
were a really cool suit that had all
those flowers on it and he looked
sensational and we really appreciate
when straight guys actually jump into
the theme and dress up um Tami and
Charles also went in camis dress was
sensational with the yellow and then the
big blue bow Charles looked great in
hand it's like funky little suit but
like Oh lily and coal and then
madellaine posted that picture in that
really cool light blue dress and she
looked like the fairy godmother of
Cinderella but really chic oh they all
looked great big props to the railroad
Outkast adore them so much I can't wait
to tell them oh and also while we're
talking about this you guys go give
Ashley Marie some props because Katie
Keene got picked up so we are gonna be
seeing a new Riverdale spin-off coming
to the CW this fall and Ashley Marie
will be back as Josie at Stars Lucy Hale
from Pretty Little Liars as Katie Keene
I'm very excited to see it
and once I see the pilot I will tweet my
thoughts so once again follow me on
Twitter if you want to I don't care okay
we are going to start wrapping it up I
know I said that a while ago but you
guys are chiming in with some really
great stuff mmm
sky sim Claire there's a pic of you
there's a pic on insta of tawny in a
hospital gown with nurses nothing better
happened to Tony Tony is in a hospital
gown yeah that's all I'm going to say
Tony's in a hospital gown things get
crazy I have no idea what's going on
anymore
you're gonna watch this episode and
you're gonna do what is happening and
then you're gonna come to the Sweetwater
after-show and hear all my hot takes on
it because it's particularly funny if I
do say so myself but that also could be
because I wrote it this morning at a
very early time with two cups of coffee
in my system and nothing else and I you
know what I think we're gonna end it
right there thank you guys we're done
thank you so much for tuning in to the
Sweetwater secrets preview for episode
321 and be sure to check back with me
after you've watched chapter 56 the
secret of Harvest House so we can all
freak out together over the insanity
that goes down but first please give
this video a like and validate my
craziness hit the subscribe button so
you never miss these last few episodes
of Sweetwater and then tell me all your
thoughts in the comments and hey look
there's my Twitter handle
now are you ready for these final two
episodes what twists do you think are
coming what couples are using I have you
been missing the most tell me everything
a few after the episode of snow tires
love you river babes bye
[Music]
you